I think the official title of the talk
was robust deep learning under the
distribution ship but I don't write
election for one line avoiding line
breaks when possible in slides don't be
alarmed so I'm going to talk about the
work that started with
yeah so never go so maybe maybe a tie to
tie this into something the broader
themes have come up the last couple days
I guess I started at some point trying
to figure out what people were talking
about when they were writing all these
interpretability papers it's just a
young machine learning person doing
supervised learning like anyone else
and it seemed like there's a weird
combination of people had a lot of valid
concerns about cases we're doing
prediction alone is a problem and at the
same time a menu of solutions that
wasn't clear if it addressed any let
alone all those problems and then maybe
started trying to go down the rabbit
hole of some of those concerns whether
they were estimating causal effects or
sort of external validity you know
somehow generalizing to a different
distribution this is actually I guess I
guess distribution shift or domain
adaptation is a bit of a gateway drug
for causality so warnings to anyone who
starts thinking about it eventually
you'll have to ask why the distribution
shift and then you'll find that you're
familiar assumptions map onto causal
assumption so so this work spans a few
papers started with this paper together
with a nice young Wang and Alex mola on
detecting and correcting for label shift
which is a pretty classical kind of
rigid assumption but where we could say
concrete things expand it into the
empirical and I'll kind of talk about a
couple follow-ups here one about just
detecting shift generally one about how
we correct for it and whether the
techniques that are like familiar
toolbox for correcting for shifting
distributions are still valid in the
context of deep learning and finally
I'll talk about a recent paper it's not
actually the title of the paper but
maybe it communicates irrelevant
take-home about a recent family of
methods called domain adversarial
approaches that are intended to correct
for distribution shift but do so under
unstated and
often violated assumptions so this work
is with a bunch of collaborators I'm
making this slide it was kind of
reminded of the stark gender imbalance
in the field and my maybe failure to do
more so there should be a 1 in 256
chance of this happening and hopefully
never again so basically the high-level
problem here is supervised learning
setup says some process let's just say
God makes lots of data fall out of the
sky and we use it to train a model and
now that model has the ml algorithm has
produced a function and we're gonna
apply it in the future I'm more data
that hopefully also falls out of the sky
but from like a copy-pasted god that has
had no change of opinion in the
intervening period and then you know
basically if we did good on health alec
representatives from the source
distribution we should do well at test
time and a target distribution and the
reality is just you know the real world
is complicated and we have no idea
what's going on but there's there's many
many manifestations of different kinds
of real-world mechanisms that give rise
to this difference between the data we
see at train time and in the desired
deployment setting some of them kind of
benign some of them where we have some
kind of you know let's do some
introspection about our sort of moral
role in this world and some of them you
know somewhere in between so i mean
you've heard a lot about adversarial
examples i won't spend too much time
talking about them that's one case where
we basically assumed that up to some
changes within a small neighborhood the
new distribution and the old
distribution are basically the same and
that like
you know they did a process for creating
the new data as you sample a point from
the old distribution and then move it
within a little ball perhaps you know
most of the attention is on adversarial
examples rightly sort of because it's
intriguing for the very reason that
we're intrigued broadly by the
perceptive qualities of capacity of
convolutional neural networks and use
this new ability perhaps maybe the most
common like real-world adversarial
attack that people have been dealing
with for a long time is people trying to
get by spam filters so you want to keep
the message more or less the same you
want to keep the image the email
qualitatively similar but you want to
monkey with the spelling to bypass
whether it's back of words keyword
filters whatever it is so a recent paper
at ACL here I won't go into details but
basically it turns out if you take say a
sentiment classifier you can you know
based on state-of-the-art techniques
like fine-tuning a giant Bert sort of
fill in the blank language model type
thing to your downstream fast you can
[ __ ] the model basically bring it
down from ninety percent accuracy to
works in random guessing by just
altering one card there so it's not a
phenomena Civic to two images but
there's also problems in text text a
little bit funkier because there's no
such thing as an in perceptual change
unless it's like you've got a font where
lower case ELLs in upper case eyes look
the same another kind of failure mode is
that we don't actually have a training
data from even the realistic deployment
setting so things like reading
comprehension or question answering a
lot of times what we're doing is we're
creating synthetic data sets that we
hope are somehow related to the
downstream task or gonna put them out
there and in a paper at an email P last
year with one student we we showed that
basically these tasks they called
reading comprehension - just to make you
question what comprehension means at all
and force you to develop new vocabulary
it's really just question answering the
inputs consist of a passage and a
question
the
put consists of some often there's many
ways of setting it up sometimes it's
multi-class prediction very often it's a
span in the passage which is the answer
to the question these datasets are often
created programmatically in a way that
people think somehow is close enough to
the task that if you could solve it
you're really doing something like
reading comprehension or they're created
by being crowdsource
it turns out that there's enough
weaknesses and this sort of data
synthesis pipelines that there's all
these papers out there basically
claiming that they've made serious
progress on this problem they propose a
deep neural network it does this it
looks at the question looks at the
answer jointly aligns them non jointly
aligns them that puts them back together
it stirs them around and then eventually
you know uses the fact that it's really
read the question in the passage to make
an answer and it turns out that if you
take a lot of those very same models in
your place to question with a random
question that was not in any way
correlated with this particular instance
of the label they get the same accuracy
so if you're not solving the task you
think you are it's another way things go
wrong sometimes we are the agents of
change and I think this is something
we're thinking about more often is that
kinda insidiously we deploy machine
learning that were the sort of validity
the system is based on the
representativeness of historical data
where that historical data is something
like user behavior and then we deploy it
in a context whose very purpose is
behavior modification surprisingly um
things get weird so on the other hand
you might think let's let's just you
know come up with one model that's
robust to everything so you know what's
this just fine the model and that sounds
appealing and there may be certain
assumptions under which you can do it
but you can't in general like domain
adaptation is I think this is something
that you know if there's a criticism of
I say this maybe there's a
self-identifying deep learning person
there's a criticism of us from maybe
more quarters like this it's often that
we are plowing into areas not really
aware of
things that are just already known in
this case I'm staring at tribe in
dahveed who is intimately familiar with
impossibilities concerning domain
adaptation but we have a lot of papers
just say we're stopped we solve domain
adaptation we are we per port to solve
it or even address it but defined only
just the source and target distribution
are different from each other that's
just a ill specified problem it's
impossible and you could just come up
with cases where you like the right
answer truly is different depending on
what assumption you make so I kind of
wish I didn't put that jiff there
because it's giving me anxiety right now
basically no classifier will work well
in all distributions you can guarantee
performance with strong assumptions and
that'll be like the first part of this
talk typical assumptions of things like
bounded divergence between the source
and target distribution by some some
measure others is like assumed in
variances you assume some kind of
invariance class when common things to
assume invariance on one of the
conditional distribution so either
probability of Y given X like a labeling
function doesn't change or probability
of x given Y doesn't change that's the
assumption I'll talk about the bit today
it's the anti causal assumption or the
class conditionals don't change but you
know it's just worth noting you know
when when when X doesn't cause Y so say
when Y causes X and if you don't assume
realisability which is a case we're sort
of both covariance shift and label shift
do hold they're like you know the
labeling function actually does change
so you truly don't have one model that
is the robust model because the right
prediction as far simon target time is
different
so if i see someone who has a cough
today i do not think they are a zombie
there but if the zombie apocalypse
happens tomorrow and I find out that you
know it turns out zombies which is
normally very rare but now is 80% of
population and one of the early symptoms
this cough you know by my probability
that they are a zombie has gone up only
just because the prevalence of you know
zombie itis has changed information of
the zombie um there okay so so first
part we'll talk about detecting and
correcting for label shift so here's the
thought experiment know anything about
this field I was just kind of
starting to think about these problems
and I had this kind of motivation it was
sort of rain a classifier and say I'm
looking at like x-rays pretty clean
pneumonia it's gonna be like not a very
realistic example just kind of
motivation is that it's hell you know
it's a rare disease most people don't
have it I'm trying to predict it based
on just looking at randomly sampled
x-rays chest x-rays say I've run a
classifier in the training data you know
and more or less it's not totally
accurate for everyone but it predicts
roughly you know the right percentage of
people have pneumonia I run on
validation data it seems that it's also
kind of in line with what I expect to
see I read it in the wild you know and
this is still when I trained it and it's
giving me saying estimating roughly the
same fraction of people seem to have
pneumonia and I feel pretty good and
then you know some some period of time
goes by this is just what Google thinks
an epidemic looks like this is not a
pneumonia patient I think it's an Ebola
victim but you know I run the classifier
in the wild at some point in the future
and now suddenly the classifier tells me
five percent of people have pneumonia
and so on one hand you could just think
like this is great I trained this thing
for purposes of doing some kind of like
public health monitoring or
quantification and now it's told me that
the the fraction of labels has changed
on the other hand this tells me like the
the distribution of outputs in my
classifiers change this means the
distribution of inputs to my classifier
is changed why should I believe anything
in fact if I went out instead of feeding
in chest x-rays I fed in cats would it
tell me that point zero five percent we
say there's no change in the rate of
pneumonia no and my experience is this
is purely not a mathematical insight but
like a deep learning elbow grease
insight is I expected I have evidence on
different slide when I do this I suspect
either 0% or 100% of people will have
pneumonia when I feed it guess
no there is no valid answer no that's
neither have nor don't have human
pneumonia or something
another way of motivating thinking about
label shift is just that we have this
funky way of doing things which is we
train classifiers say like image
classification and typical thing to do
is just go out and collect data with a
uniform label distribution train a
classifier deployed in the wild and you
could wind up in weird situations like
you get some accuracy but then you
deploy it in a wild with some randomly
chosen not randomly chosen but it's like
whatever is natural in the world label
distribution and you sort of let's say
you had like balanced errors you know
you have like all your off diagonals and
the confusion matrix we're equal you
deploy in the wild you're still gonna
get 70% accuracy but you've suddenly
once once you encounter a non uniform
label this vision the problems gotten
much easier maybe it's 80% cats out
there and you're still getting 70%
accuracy and so the question is you know
can we you know the high level
motivation is here is basically can we
detect that there's a shift can we
estimate precisely what it is under what
assumptions and can we can we use this
information to recover a better
classifier like on the fly without
actually getting new labels humans
actually can do this and I feel a little
bit embarrassed that I I sent an email
to a bunch of friends I knew who were
cognitive scientists I figure would be
able to give me as evidence of like
humans kind of without any additional
supervision that's updating to
statistics of some calf they were
solving and they pointed me to an IC ml
paper these are a bunch of psychologists
so I probably should have done a better
lit review on my own before I bothered
them but basically there's a nice paper
from 2010 at ICML called the thing is
this is what it's called I don't have to
read it a lot I guess and then scrapper
they call the test item effect and the
basically the idea is they train people
on these like very artificial tasks
they're like you know you give them some
number of training examples they say
these are weebles these are squeals or
something can you differentiate we put
some Squibbles but then they do is they
randomly choose people to show them test
sets with different distributions all
you're able to show is that basically by
varying the statistics of the test set
you can cause people to classify you
know basically the same person show
different fractions that's weebles or
Squibbles at test time will sort of
update their prior and will classify it
like the same image as a weeble versus
cui bull
perhaps you know get under some amount
of uncertainty because you know it's
like that thing of like you you
recognize you're going through a test in
iran's hey actually i noticed that you
know the the the multiple-choice answers
are not actually uniform they're
actually there's more d's and now that I
know there's more D's if I went back if
I previously would have been equivocal
between two answers maybe now now I
actually know I'm more inclined to guess
it's D so the formal set of domain
adaptation is about source distribution
we're gonna call them P we're gonna call
the target distribution Q I've already
been doing that without introducing it
but hopefully I think confusing and the
typical setup here in this people--some
who's called the standard domain
adaptation problems we call it
unsupervised omein adaptation don't
assume i have labeled data from the
source distribution unlabeled data from
the target distribution my goal is to
predict it well on the test issue or the
target distribution at test time without
seeing you know when I say well I mean
sort of to get to do better than I would
have if I didn't look at the unlabeled
test data or at least in the setting of
shift to do better but you know only
only using the the only additional
information I have is this unlabeled
input data from from the target
distribution and you know I have to do
this right again without seeing any
actual labels so right our goal the tech
data shift has occurred estimate the new
label distribution correct the
classifier and again just reminder from
our pneumonia example that you know if
if you know if our if our class is the
distribution of our classifiers outputs
change that's enough to already tell us
something something has changed so right
this problem is again in general
impossible right but there are certain
restrictive assumptions that make it
quite possible
one is label shift so this is what this
paper is initially about and all we're
gonna assume is the only thing that
changes is the label marginal so we're
assuming a generative process we're
basically y cos x or we don't have to be
assuming it but this is a natural
consequence of a setting where Y causes
X which is appropriate in cases like
diagnosis because like you know you're
trying to predict the cause from the
symptoms which is different from you
know as we'll get through covariation
so because the anti call it's sort of
you know it's maybe I'm being slightly
lying here so it's done it makes the
causal anti causal assumption but it's
implied by the anti causal assumption
essentially what we're saying is that
you know we could this is how the
distribution factorizes where we could
just carry over the class conditional
distribution from source time and
there's a nice paper that kind of works
through by bernard shell cough called on
causal ninety calls of learning that
just walks through kind of gently a
bunch of different assumptions about
distribution shift and what are the
corresponding causal assumptions that
would have led you to assume that kind
of invariance about the the conditional
probabilities contrast this with
covariant shift which makes the opposite
assumption is this is sort of i sample
and x but then given X the probability
of Y given X is what's unchanged over
time and that's the case I think that is
often it still might be not given enough
like they might not be assuming shared
support and so it still might be under
specified but I think this kind of case
this assumption it is it's sort of
implicit in a lot of say like the
adversarial type things where we're
basically assuming that it's there's
there's a true labeling function and
that it doesn't change the same image at
source time and target time should map
to the same label if you if you just
knew the right function so it's we're
thinking about that we maybe over fit
some of our insights to the terminus
take like classification problems you
know over fits like realizability and
over fit maybe even the way we talk
about way we teach prediction is we
obviously as a labeling function which
sort of the kind of it sounds like
described as a structural model where Y
is given
rise to by X versus you know you can
also still predict Y even if X was
produced as a consequence of Y first you
know the opposite right so now
covariates chips is appealing in some
ways because well you know in the domain
adaptation setting you have samples of
the input from source and target so it's
sort of appealing to think that the the
likelihood ratio that I would know how
to estimate is Q of X over P of X
because I have samples of from from Q of
X and from P of X but the problem is
just that that doesn't help us when
that's the wrong assumption so if you're
if you're in label shift assumption you
apply a covariant shift correction that
doesn't help you so the idea here is
we're just going to introduce a very
simple consistent estimator for the test
at label distribution it's one nice
thing about it is it's gonna exploit the
fact that we have good black box
predictors already and all we need is
like a good predictor on the training
distribution under the label shift
assumptions to be able to accurately
estimate if you'll be able to accurately
estimate the label distribution on the
test set we're gonna use the black box
predictor intuitively at a high level
for dimensionality reduction we're going
to use it to get away from ever having
to think in and this is sort of
motivated by I'm not just I'm a
practitioner so I'm not just thinking
like hey there's X and there's Y they're
sort of fundamentally the same kind of
object I'm motivated by the kind of case
where X is I image and so it's 120,000
dimensions are higher and Y is something
usually comparatively simple like a
classification in this case we're thing
about multi-class classification our
classifier doesn't have to be calibrated
it doesn't have to be unbiased but the
better our classifier is the the tighter
our bounds on the estimate of the test
set label distribution but regardless
you know as long as our class our
classifier is not degenerate and by
which I mean it doesn't have a
degenerate confusion matrix on the train
or des it doesn't matter it's the same
condition then then we will be able to
get a consistent estimator so as long as
we have enough labeled training data and
unlabeled test data
so the assumptions are just one the
label ship assumption class conditional
is the same - we needed an
identifiability assumption like we
basically we can't recognize labels
we've never seen before so every every
label we're gonna see a test time has to
be a label we've already seen a target
time
sorry a source time and we're assuming
this is just the assumptions before we
assuming of access to a classifier who's
expected confusion matrix is invertible
and the idea is really simple we're just
gonna look at the expected confusion
matrices on of the same classifier on
the source and the target data and these
are different objects from each other
however they're only different actually
because ones once I fixed a class you
know the the distribution of outputs of
our classifier is a function of you know
given Y which it probably of X given Y
is the same as source and target this is
the only difference between these two
confusion matrices is that they're the
columns are scaled differently so if I
look at the column normalized confusion
matrices so this is like given that Y is
a particular label you know what
fraction of the x is a classifier output
you know each of the classes and it's
easiest to think of it that way actually
this doesn't even have to be the
classifier output this could be just
this could be the softmax outputs to the
classifier it could be any of K labels
could be any K dimensional function but
it makes sense that if I just picked a
random representation in the classifier
it's not necessarily obvious to me that
the classifier is going to learn
something such as this matrix would be
invertible if I break it down this way
however it's clear that it should be if
this is the confusion matrix because
basically you know your classifier
doesn't even have to be that good for
the confusion matrix to be sort of
diagonally dominated right you just have
to predict when it's class I you predict
I slightly more than the other classes
like you can still be pretty inaccurate
and have an invertible confusion matrix
so on the source data I can use source
data because this guy is the same for
source and target I can use a source say
to estimate this confusion matrix the
test data I can't break it down by
column like at this average them all I
could just say what's the mean
prediction and then I just put these
guys together
it's really simple I just have I have a
linear system in the solution to the
linear system is actually the quantity
that I'm after it is the test set label
distribution and now the only tricky
part is that the quality of this
recovery is going to depend on how well
I estimate the confusion matrix it's
going to depend on how well I estimate
this mean vector and it's also going to
depend on the quality of my classifier
because I have to invert this matrix to
solve the linear system and so basically
this is going to depend on the smallest
eigen value of the confusion matrix and
that's going to be I guess maybe what's
interesting there just that this is a
different notion of accuracy than I'm
used to thinking about when I say I want
a good classifier I kind of very
accurate classifier that has two
identical columns and the confusion
matrix for rare classes but otherwise
does it does a you know knockout job on
the rest of them you can just imagine
this would happen if I was looking at
the actual confusion made like the hard
thresholded confusion matrix for a
deterministic classifier and two of my
classes were kind of rare and so the
models never put them as the Arg banks
even if it's kind of discriminative this
is one reason why maybe working with a
soft max is a little bit more reliable
than working with the hard labels so
right we just solve this problem if you
go back to working with like the
original confusion matrix not the column
normalized you have the same thing it's
just that what you're solving for now
isn't Q of Y but it's actually cube Y
divided by P of Y it's the vector of
importance weights so consistent in that
basically this guy's an average is going
to converge to its mean this is also the
mean classifier output on the target
date is also going to converge to its
mean you can prove that basically as n
grows large if the expected expected
confusion matrix is invertible the
comparable confusion matrix will also be
invertible and you get this simple error
bound basically this is a few things one
we have this sort of inverse Podrick
dependency on the condition number of
the confusion mate of the expected
confusion matrix our we're gonna have a
sort of irreducible error that's
determined either by the number of
examples we have to estimate the
confusion matrix a number of
examples or the number of you know
target distribution test examples and
we're also going to depend upon the the
norm of the vector of importance weights
so what that sort of tells you is that I
think you know this maybe is an obvious
thing actually but maybe it gives a nice
formal way of saying that maybe maybe
what we're doing in the first place of
saying I'm gonna construct data sets
that I have a uniform distribution over
the labels is actually a good idea and
you know it basically controls this term
it's saying hey if you know if I have a
very rare label at train time I'm
increasing my error in a sticking out
what the target time the the test time
label distribution is so I can just use
a uniform label distribution at train
time but instead of just using that
classifier directly I can use that
classifier at target time to figure out
what the target label distribution is
and then go back and correct my
classifier but as long as my label data
comes from you know you know having a
uniform label distribution on the on the
labeled data puts me in the best
position to do this recovery and then I
can do the adjustment subsequently
like you're going to estimate the test
set label distribution and you're going
to estimate it imperfectly and how
imperfectly depends on the number of
samples you have if you're going to sort
of entertain the idea the label you know
that there's if P equals Q you're still
going to estimate it correctly plus or
minus Epsilon and if you know that that
might mean that you you do slightly
worse than if you just assume there's no
shift it's not a corrective for that is
if if you kind of have a prior belief
that like there's a good chance the
distribution doesn't change at all but
then I just want to be guarded against
the worst-case scenario like I want my
default to be to not change you could
have set some tolerance like that's a
hack but you could just say hey unless
unless I estimate that there's a
significant difference my default is not
actually act upon this if I'm only going
to correct my classifier if I think
there's a significant discrepancy and
that would cover you so that way
basically you'd only be making a change
if I were you know 1 minus Delta sure
that there was this is a worst-case
about yeah very well becomes greater
than to something that and it may be
loose so the easy case of vehicle scale
exactly thank you so we can use this
also for detection like 1 you know when
you look at that matrix your eyes well
if this guy's invertible then basically
the the test set label distribution is
going to change if it only under the
label shift assumption we're still
working on the label shift assumption
right but if that holds then then the
label distribution changes if and only
if the mean classifier output changes
and so we could just look to the mean
classifier output as now it's sufficient
if we assume label shift to detect
distribution shift just by looking at
the classifier outputs
and this is important because it turns
out two sample testing so there's a nice
result by a ditch around us who knows
who knows the area is so much better
than I do basically two sample testing
is easy and low dimensions and hard in
very high dimensions and so now we get
to say I'm gonna use my classifier
output as the object of plan which I'm
going to test for distribution shift so
you know if if the if they testify if
the classifier output is just like the
heart thresholded output I could just
basically I can just do a likelihood
ratio test it's like the right thing to
do in practice we found when we use the
the softmax
outputs of the classifier as the columns
of our confusion matrix that's like the
mean the mean softmax output for each
condition on each class then what we
could do is just look we could look at
the like per component and do a KS test
and then use some kind of correction and
so basically just find that when there's
no shift our type 1 error is controlled
the greater the shift you know the the
more power for our test not surprising
we also look at using you know
classifiers of various strengths they've
been trained to different degrees the
better the classifier gets the more
power we have for detecting shift which
should not be surprising if the
classifier you know at 100 percent
accuracy then good shape here's our
estimation errors this is compared to
previous approaches when I think is
basically so the previous approaches
were sort of adopted kinda like kernel
mean matching to the the label shift
scenario and a problem there is you know
we're dealing with something like images
just we wind up with kind of a
irreducible error because we just don't
have a great similarity function but our
our estimator here is actually a
consistent estimator
and the more examples we get you know we
just we just head towards zero in terms
of estimating and test at label
distribution you know it's worth noting
that maybe there's a like a temporal
bias that if I were developing the
method ten years ago or 20 years ago I
might be more concerned about like the
one to two thousand example range and
think that my method was worse and the
fact that we like cross over at you know
somewhere between two thousand four
thousand examples it's more significant
in a world where we you know typically
have more than that amount of data now
we can we can apply so what we've done
here this is kind of a weird plot I only
realize after I created it and published
a paper that this is a weird plot to
people is that what we have are two
different types of simulated shift and
as you go to the right the shift is
getting greater and you'll notice our
method is and we're using a kind of weak
classifier use a perfect classifier and
you're doing image classification it
doesn't matter gonna be perfect always
doesn't matter if you have more cats or
more dogs who are using a multi-layer
perceptron for image classification you
might people would say why are you doing
better as the shift gets worse the
reason why we're doing better as the
shift gets worse is because we're going
from a uniform distribution toward
something is dominated by one class in
this case we're doing it by just making
one class and we're averaging over all
the possible guys making one class more
common and rescaling the others here
we're doing it by basically sampling the
label distribution from madera Schley
where this is like the concentration
parameter and showing confidence over
over multiple runs so that the
concentration parameter the dish like
it's really small it's also dominated by
just one class so that's an easy problem
like if you go all the way out to the
right the blind classifier gives 100%
accuracy yeah when you see
I mean are you doing the shift in
training and testing or only in training
on the in testing okay so I got that
detail thank you where we train the
classifier we use the classifier with
together with the unlabeled data to
estimate the test set label marginal
once we know the label marginal the
question is how do you use that to make
your classifier better how are we
getting a better classifier and I'm
trying to trim slides to fit in more
material but I somehow left out the
house it's really important there's two
things you could do if you believe that
you truly like if you really think that
you have a model that's giving you
predictive probabilities
there's a there's a plugin correction
right like like there's there's a simple
I'm just going to take my predictive
distribution re weight every answer by
the likelihood ratio and then rescale
that's the right thing to do question is
does a neural network which is what
you're using that first place give you
give you probabilities do you believe it
you believe that they give you you know
anything like a calibrated probability
and as you'll see soon there's reason to
believe no and in that case what do you
do well what we did in this case we do
is important weighted risk minimization
so we went back reweighed the examples
and retrained and where we'll get to in
just a second if i can actually get that
far is there's a question then of what
if anything is the role of importance
weighted risk minimization when you're
training a deep neural network and I
think make sure smiling cuz you know you
know it's a interpolation will give you
the same answer regardless of how you
weight the examples right so if you're
truly interpolating so the next step
that we did is we looked at through this
and said actually you know this gives us
kind of a general pipeline for detecting
shift right because what we did is I
turned out what we said hey we have a
great representation for detecting shift
under the label shift assumption which
is just a classifier output so it was
very low dimensional representation
which is sufficient for detecting shifts
we just need to detect shift in this ten
dimensional object not in this you know
three thousand dimensional object and
I'm just going to do the appropriate to
sample test and then
the question that we had thereafter was
okay let's say that cats became more
common in the real world it's never
going to be the case like our so
basically we have a nice kind of result
here that's only nice in a world that
you just do not live in right to be like
kind of humble of how like the
applicability you just the the class in
it like if cats became you know went
from being 20% of photos to 80% of
photos there's multiple subspecies of
cap and they're completely unrelated to
each there's no way that they all
increased in prevalence at the exact
same rate and you went from like you
know this number of like Siamese cats
and this number of Persian cats to like
they stayed in exactly the same
proportions it increased ago the class
conditionals do not stay the same people
talk about more sports now than they did
a week ago if you're looking at like
topic you know classifying topics but
now they're talking about something else
last week they were talking about
Women's World Cup and I don't know you
know maybe somewhere in the interim that
we're talking about Wimbledon so the
question though is okay so so if if the
labels you know if the label
distribution change is and the class
conditional distribution is truly fixed
we have a good detector the question is
well let's say the class conditionals
don't stay the same
now we know an adversary could design a
distribution where our methods gonna
fail because you just come up with
you'll find you know you're doing the
mention on reduction you find any two
inputs that map on to the same output
and just shift mass among them you know
now now we're just screwed like we can't
detect this this shift is happening the
question is like what are the odds if
someone's not being adversarial that
they will choose the that we have this
thing that the text shift you know and
it's pretty good like are they are they
unless they're being adversarial what
are the odds are gonna find the
distribution the new distribution that
truly makes our classifier give the
exact same distribution of outputs and
so we tried this is an empirical study
so I make no claims that it's as telling
you this is always a good idea no claims
about how difficult it is for an
adversary just we look at lots of
different things we basically come look
at this general recipe and we say let's
do our thing which is basically take the
source distribution classifier train you
know train it use the
max outputs is our distribution and for
detecting shift alternatively let's use
the the heart thresholded outputs of our
classifier but we also look at no
reduction so we just look at the input
features which gives us a lot that's
just this one baseline it gives a tricky
you know aggregation problem where we
have to do some conservative correction
like a massive like bonferroni
correction to lose a lot of physical
power we look at what if we did PCA what
if you do a sparse random projections
what if using untrained auto encoder
what if we use a trained auto encoder
just get a general feeling and then
another baseline is sort of what would
the machine learning person who doesn't
really know about to sample testing do
and know might be they were just
training discriminative classifiers to
try to tell the two distributions apart
and the interesting answer is it seems
that across a whole wide range of
different shifts this is you know the
paper has specific results I don't even
know it's meaningful to look at
aggregate but this is this is an
aggregate plot across many many
different types of ships whether it's
adversarial examples rotations like just
a large empirical study it seems across
the board and this is like with a number
of examples that we have to use for for
detecting shift we get better accuracy
actually using our training set
classifier as our representation for
trying to detect shift and and then all
of these other things so on not
adversarial perturbations that seems to
in general be the case one interesting
thing is that on adversarial
perturbations and this is just
adversarial perturbations are created by
the one step like fast gradient method
or whatever here strangely a thing that
the text that the text is shift right
away is often looking at the original
input pixels like just look doing KL
tests on on the input pixels can detect
it really quickly although I'm sure an
even smarter adversary could just come
up with a way of maintaining the pixel
marginals or something this is the same
test applied Ludvig pointed out so we
ran it yesterday on on ludwig 10 versus
CFR 10 he pointed out rightly that no
test that uses a convolutional neural
network at all since the entire
methodology owes somewhat to the see if
our data is that
you know B with absolute unimpeachable
integrity B claim to detect shift on CFR
10 because maybe everything is fit to
the actual C part n training in test
sets I won't go to war with him on that
I see the point but anyway you see with
about a hundred examples you're able to
detect there's a shift and by comparison
this is what you would get if you know
you're training a classifier to just try
to predict it by the way classifier gets
about fifty five fifty six percent
accuracy at detecting Ludwick denver's
CFR ten all right make sure maybe a
girls in Beckett 2n or Ben 10 so I'll
try to hustle through I think we're
getting close but I like five minutes
design okay so one problem is we
corrected to put the shift by using
importance weighting I presents what if
anything is the role of importance
waiting in combination of deep learning
so we have a body of literature that you
know makes clear that importance waiting
is a good idea when we have models
fistina specification and like hi model
bias so like we have thing like a linear
model it's may specified and we say well
you know if we if we know that we only
have to look at like this region of the
input data weary wait to say only this
half is important then we're gonna get
out a different predictor but what got
me thinking was I saw not to give a talk
on where his work with Daniel in Israel
a little while ago of a year and a half
ago or a year ago and you have the date
describe this work and it's granted it's
only it's analyzing linear networks and
extended to deep linear networks and
convolutional linear networks but in all
cases they they said what is the
implicit bias of SGD what is the
separator that it finds on separable
data and what they find is that STD
leads to the solution that is based like
a it's a hard margin SVM solution and
you get something slightly different as
you change the architecture but what
bothered me about it is the heart this
solution doesn't care what the
importance weights are it doesn't care
if we over sample from one of the
classes and so if we go to deep neural
networks for which all data sets at
least these image data sets are all that
the training sets are all separable
then what if anything are we doing by
putting in importance waiting because
these results from my paper that I've
published that say that we get a big
advantage and now I'm you know
questioning my sanity and I want to know
basically what you know why does
importance weighting matter because once
you fit everything perfectly and then I
like to just blow up the norm of my
output way so I get arbitrarily close to
zero error it doesn't matter what the
importance weights are yeah I could
change the apart I could push all of
them to zero with the same classifier so
I could look at a 2d example and so this
is with no importance weights and this
is the redline is like linear separator
and then the colored lines are just
brute-force plotting the decision
boundary of a neural network and you
know over time basically the the the
neural network and the linear model give
you basically the exact same decision
boundary if I change the importance
weights and I look at what happens over
time what happens is like you know here
I'm uploading the blue points I have a
big effect early in training that
basically is gonna move out and by the
time I get to like epoch 10,000 it's
very similar to the original decision
boundary and saying the other way you
know if I avoid the green points so it
seems that I have this I do have an
impact of importance waiting this is a
way of somehow alternating yeah altering
the optimization by by incorporating but
only modulo the early stopping criteria
so I've expressed now how much I'm
correcting for distribution shifts or
what I think I'm doing in terms of like
the wrong abstraction now I'm not tuning
the early stopping knob to try to impose
my prior which just seems like I don't
know what is the correct level of early
stopping now this is not 2d data but see
far data so I look and say basically I'm
gonna try weights all the way from like
five twelve to one one direction in five
twelve to one the other direction and
I'm basically going to look at over
epochs of training you know what
fraction of images are classified as
dogs versus cats this dog versus cats
see far just too classy for binary
classification you see early in training
there's a huge effect that disappears in
overtime like these guys are not even in
the order of the importance weights this
is just because of like Ryan
runs so basically what happens I'm a big
effect that tapers off towards nothing
and basically up to like importance
weightings of 256 to one which is right
bigger than you'd normally want to use
just cuz you're reducing your effective
sample size you'll eventually converge
to like the same exact decision
qualitatively I'm not saying it's the
exact I can't visualize you know three
thousand dimensional lost service or
whatever but you're you're getting
qualitatively in that these models are
basically if we look at fraction of this
is at epoch you know one thousand after
one w box we look at fraction of cats
that are classified as dogs it's the
same across the importance weights
something funky happens at like 512 or
256 sometimes it blows up but other than
that fraction of dogs that are
classified as dogs is level also you
know of random vectors just truly random
vectors like uniformly sampled in input
space they are all cats this is just
like a weird thing that happens but
there's no right answer right if you say
the model is constrained to say it's got
a probability it's you know the sum of
the probability it's a cat and probably
it's a dog has to be one and if it's
neither the models sort of just
fundamentally you know semantically
incoherent interestingly I think this
motivated by the intuition from Nazi and
Daniels paper has said that the the
conversion to this sort of weight
agnostic solution is related to the the
norm of the weights blowing up we
realize that what happens if use LT
regularization l2 regularization does
change the decision boundary you get a
different decision boundary when you use
importance weighting if you have LT
regularization however now I have
another knob that's also sort of the
wrong knob so the final thing to say
here importance weighting can affect
deep learning but only via like kind of
the wrong abstractions and there's the I
have no guidance for what the right way
to choose them so this is like a serious
problem it might even be I think a
conventional wisdom for a long time has
been don't down sample your data weight
it and it's possible may be that you
actually should down sample your data I
don't know I have to think it through
and finally we looked at domain
adversarial networks and I don't I think
I'm
time so I'm gonna end here but basically
you know I think this is a cautionary
tale what happens if we don't for not
you know we could be very precise about
under what assumptions we develop a
model that's correct and then we could
even try that model and cases where the
assumption doesn't hold and be clear
about that but there's a whole
industries thousands of citations a
whole whole you know almost subfield
look people reviewing the same subfields
papers who are saying we the way to deal
with domain adaptation is you make a
representation such as the source data
and target look the same in
representation space there's a problem
with that which is that the easy counter
example is precisely we've been talking
about the whole talk it's a label shift
if the label distribution is different
and you make them look identical and
representations face then and you're
applying the same predictor on top of
that representation your lower bounding
your error you're basically saying if I
had 75% 25% in flips to 25 75 then by
forcing them to look the same in
representation space I'm actually going
to say have to get at least like 50%
error so so this is a big problem and
there's a theorem that Shaw has invoked
as the like this is the right thing to
do because there's a bound on the target
area that depends on three terms and we
minimize two of them the problem is they
minimize us sufficient but not necessary
conditions and the term that gets max
sometimes gets maximized by this
minimization is it's actually an
irreducible error like they're
maximizing the discrepancy between you
know the accurate you know between what
is now in representation space the
labeling function on source and the
labeling function on target so you know
you can think of it just as a picture
like this what they end up doing is they
end up saying in order to make them look
the same if I have you know different
class balances I have to like siphon off
some of these guys and push them over
there and the reason why they think it's
a good idea is well just two things
going on one is that there's a little
bit of sleight of hand in the way
experimental results are reported so we
found these things are much less stable
than they're reported
times you know variance on errors aren't
clear whether they're talking about
standard deviation or variance and makes
a big difference one hint but it's like
you know point for verse 0.016 or
something and the other thing that's
going on is they're actually always
looking at uniform label distributions
because they're looking at like eminence
verse s v hn and nobody's thinking about
what's the assumption that you're making
which is I think really really dangerous
so we the other party's problems ill
specified right like they are they're
looking at distributions often that have
different support so anyway you know you
can see how things go wrong we have a
correction to the method that doesn't
make it guaranteed to work but at least
makes it not guaranteed to fail in the
obvious cases and you know I think
there's a lot more work to do here so
anyway thanks so much for your time and
sorry for running a couple minutes